The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's
get started.
We're going to essentially
finish up on
Poisson processes today.
And today, we have the part of
it that's really the fun part.
What we had until now was the
dry stuff, defining everything
and so forth.
As I said before, Poisson
processes are these perfect
processes where everything that
could be true is true.
And you have so many different
ways of looking at problems
that you can solve problems
in a wide variety of ways.
What you want try to do in the
problem set this week is to
get out of the mode of starting
to write equations
before you think about it.
I mean, write equations, yes,
but while you're doing it,
think about what the right way
of approaching the problem is.
As far as I know, every part of
every problem there can be
solved in one or two lines.
There's nothing long.
There's nothing complicated.
But you have to find exactly
the right way of doing it.
And that's what you're supposed
to learn because you
find all sorts of processes in
the world, which are poorly
modelled as Poisson processes.
You get a lot of insight about
the real process by looking at
Poisson processes, but you don't
get the whole story.
And if you don't understand how
these relationships are
connected to each other then
you have no hope of getting
some sense of when Poisson
process theory is telling you
something and when it isn't.
That's why engineers are
different than mathematicians.
Mathematicians live in
this beautiful world.
And I love it.
I love to live there.
Love to go there for vacations
and so on because everything
is perfectly clean.
Everything has a
right solution.
And if it's not a
right solution,
it's a wrong solution.
In engineering, everything
is kind of hazy.
And you get insights about
things when you put a lot of
insights together.
You finally make judgments
about things.
You use all sorts of
models to do this.
And what you use a course like
this for is to understand what
all these models are saying.
And then be able to use them.
So, the stuff that we'll be
talking about today is stuff
you will use all the
rest of the term.
Because everything we do,
surprisingly enough, from now
on, has some relationships
with Poisson processes.
It doesn't sound like they do,
but, in fact, they do.
And this has a lot of the things
that look like tricks,
but which are more
than tricks.
They're really what comes from
a basic understanding of
Poisson processes.
So first, I'm going to
review a little bit
what we did last time.
Poisson process is an
arrival process.
Remember what an arrival
process is.
It's just a bunch of arrival
epochs, which have some
statistics associated
with them.
And it has IID
exponentially-distributed
interarrival times.
So the time between successive
arrivals is independent from
one arrival to the next.
And it has this exponential
distribution, which is what
gives the Poisson process it's
very special characteristic.
It can be represented by
its arrival epochs.
These are the things you see
here, S1, S2, S3, and so
forth, are the arrival epochs.
If you can specify what the
probability relationship is
for this set of joint random
variables then you know
everything there is to know
about a Poisson process.
If you specify the joint
distribution of these
interarrival times, and that's
trivial because they're IID
exponentially-distributed random
variables, then you
know everything there is to
know about the process.
And if you can specify N of
t, which is the number of
arrivals up until time t for
every t then that specifies
the process completely also.
So we take the viewpoint here,
I mean, usually we view a
stochastic process as either a
sequence of random variables
or a continuum of random
variables.
Here, we're viewing as this
three ways of looking at the
same thing.
So a Poisson process is then
either the sequence of
interarrival times, the sequence
of arrival epochs,
or, what we call the counting
process, N of t at each t
greater than zero.
The arrival epochs in N of
t are related either
this way or this way.
And we talked about that.
The interarrival times
are memoryless.
In other words, they satisfy
this relationship here.
The probability that an
interarrival time Xi is
greater than t plus x, for any
t and any x, which are
positive, given that it's
greater than t.
In other words, given that
you've already wasted time t
waiting, the probability that
the time from here until the
actual occurrence occurs
is again exponential.
This is stated in conditional
form.
We stated it before in just
joint probability form.
OK, which says, that if you wait
for a while and nothing
has happened, you just
keep on waiting.
You're right where
you started.
You haven't lost anything.
You haven't gained anything.
And we said that other renewal
processes, which are IID
interarrival random variables,
you can have these heavy
tailed distributions where if
nothing happens after while
then you start to really feel
badly because you know
nothing's going to happen
for an awful lot longer.
Heavy tailed distribution's best
example is when you're
trying to catch an airplane and
they say, it's going to be
10 minutes late.
That's the worst heavy tailed
distribution there is.
And it drives you crazy.
Because I've never caught a
plane that was supposed to be
10 minutes late that wasn't
at least an hour late.
And often, it got canceled,
which makes it not a random
variable at all.
One of the things we're
interested in now, and we
talked about it a lot last
time, is you pick some
arbitrary time t, that can
be any time at all.
And you ask, how long is it from
time t-- t might be when
you arrive to wait for
a bus or something--
how long is it until
the next bus comes?
So Z is the random variable
that goes.
And you really should put
some indices on this.
But what it is is the random
variable from t until this
slow arrival here that's poking
along finally comes in.
Now, what we found is that the
interval Z, which is the time
from this arrival back
to t, is exponential.
And the way we showed that is
to say, let's condition Z on
anything we want to
condition it on.
And the things that's important
too condition it on
is the value of N of t here,
which is N. And once we
condition it on the fact that N
of t is n, we then condition
on S sub n, which is the time
that this last arrival came.
So if we condition Z on N of t
at time t and the time that
this last arrival came in, which
is S sub two, in this
case, then Z turns out to be,
again, just the time left to
wait after we've already
waited for this
given amount of time.
We then find out that Z,
conditional on these two
things that we don't understand
at all, it's just
exponential, no matter
what they are.
And since it's exponential no
matter what they are, we don't
go to the trouble of trying to
figure out what they are.
We just say, whatever
distribution they have, Z
itself, unconditionally, is
just the same exponential
random variable.
So that was one of the main
things we did last time.
Next thing we did was we started
to look at any set of
time, say t1, t2, up to t sub
k, and then we looked at the
increments.
How many arrivals occurred
between zero and t1?
between t1 and t2?
How many between t2 and t3?
So we looked at these Poisson
process increments, a whole
bunch of random variables, and
we said, these are stationary
and independent Poisson counting
processes, over their
given intervals.
In other words, if you stop the
first process, you stop
looking at this at time t1.
Then you look at this
from time t1 to t2.
You look at this one from
tk minus 1 to tk.
And you look at the last one,
the next last one, all
the way up to tk.
And there should be one
where you look at it
from tk on to t.
No, you're only looking
at k of them.
So these are the things that
you're looking at.
The statement is that these are
independent random variables.
The other statement is they're
stationary, which means, if
you look at the number of
arrivals in this interval,
here, it's a function
of t2 minus t1.
But it's not a function
of t1 alone.
It's only a function of the
length of the interval.
The number of arrivals in any
interval of length tk minus tk
minus 1 is a function only of
the length of that interval
and not of where the
interval is.
That's a reasonable way to look
at stationarity, I think.
How many arrivals come in in a
given area is independent of
where the area is.
It depends only on how
long the interval is.
OK, then we found that the
probability mass function for
N of t, and now we're just
looking from zero to t because
we know we get the same thing
over any interval, this
probability mass function is
this nice function, which
depends only and the
product lambda t.
It never depends on lambda
alone or t alone.
Lambda t to n, e to the minus
lambda t over n factorial.
What the n factorial
is doing there.
Well, it came out in
the derivation.
By the time we finish today you
should have more ideas of
where that factorial
came from.
And we'll try to understand
that.
By the stationary and
independent increment
property, we know that these two
things are independent, N
of t1 and the number of
arrivals in t1 to t.
This is a Poisson
random variable.
We know that the number of
arrivals between zero and t is
also a Poisson random
variable.
And what does that tell you?
It tells you, you don't have
to go through all of this
discrete convolution stuff.
You probably should go through
it once just for your own
edification to see that
this all works.
But for a very lazy person
like me, who likes using
arguments like this, I say,
well, these two things are
independent.
They are Poisson random
variables.
Their sum is Poisson.
And therefore, whenever you have
two independent Poisson
random variables and you add
them together, what you get is
a Poisson random variable whose
mean is the sum of the
means of the two individual
random variables.
In general, sums of independent
Poisson random
variables are Poisson with
the means adding.
Them we went through a couple of
alternate definitions of a
Poisson process.
And at this point, just from
what I've said so far, and
from reading the notes and
understanding what I've said
so far, it ought to be almost
clear that these alternate
definitions, which we
talked about last
time have to be valid.
If an arrival process has the
stationary and independent
increment properties and if N
of t has the Poisson PMF for
given lambda, and all t, then
the process is Poisson.
Now what is that saying?
I mean, we've said that if we
can specify all of the random
variables N of t for
all t, then we've
specified the process.
What does it mean to
specify a whole
bunch of random variables?
It is not sufficient to find the
distribution function of
all those random variables.
And one of the problems in the
homeworks at this time is to
explicitly show that for
a simpler process,
the Bernoulli process.
And to actually construct an
example of where N of t is
specified everywhere.
But you don't have the
independence between different
intervals, and therefore,
you don't
have a Bernoulli process.
You just have this nice binomial
formula everywhere.
But it doesn't really
tell you much.
OK, so, but here we're adding
on the independent increment
properties, which says over any
set of intervals the joint
distribution of how many
arrivals there are here, how
many here, how many here, how
many here, those joint random
variables are independent of
each other, which is what the
independent increment
property says.
So in fact, this tells you
everything you want to know
because you now know the
relationship between each one
of these intervals.
So we see why the process
is Poisson.
This one's a little trickier.
If an arrival process has the
stationary and independent
increment properties and it
satisfies this incremental
condition, then the
processes Poisson.
And the incremental condition
says that if you're looking at
the number of arrivals in some
interval of size delta, the
probability that this is equal
to N has the form 1 minus
lambda delta plus o of delta,
where n equals zero.
Lambda delta plus o of delta,
for n equals 1.
o of delta for n greater
than or equal to 2.
This intuitively is only
supposed to talk about very,
very small delta.
So if you take the Poisson
distribution lambda t to the
N, e to the minus lambda t over
n factorial, and you look
at what happens when t is
very small, this is
what it turns into.
When t is very small the
probability that there are no
arrivals in this interval of
size delta is very large.
It's 1 minus lambda delta plus
this extra term that says--
first point of view whenever
you see an o of delta is to
say, oh, that's not important.
And for N equals 1, there's
going to be one arrival with
some fudge factor, which
is not important.
And there's going to be two or
more arrivals with some fudge
factor, which is
not important.
The next thing we talked about
is that o of delta really is
defined as any function which
is a function of delta where
the limit of o of
delta divided by
delta is equal to 0.
In other words, it's some
function that goes to zero
faster than delta does.
So it's something which
is insignificant with
relationship to this as
delta gets very small.
Now, how do you use this kind
of statement to make some
statement about larger
intervals?
Well, you're clearly
stuck looking at
differential equations.
And the text does that.
I refuse to talk about
differential equations in
lecture or anyplace else.
When I retired I said, I will
no longer talk about
differential equations
anymore.
And you know, you don't need to
because you can see what's
happening here.
And what you see is happening
is, in fact, what's happening.
OK, so, that's where we
finished up last time.
And now, we come to the really
fun stuff where we want to
combine independent
Poisson processes.
And then, we want to split
And we want to play all sorts of
games with multiple Poisson
processes, which looks very
hard, and because of this,
it's very easy.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The previous
definitions, they are if and
only statements, right?
PROFESSOR: They are what?
AUDIENCE: If and only,
all Poisson
processes satisfy tho--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
OK, in other words, what you're
saying is, if you can
satisfy those properties, this
is a Poisson process.
I mean, we've already shown
that a Poisson process
satisfies those properties.
As a matter of fact, the way I
put it in the notes is these
are three alternate definitions
where you could
start out with any one of them
and derive the whole thing.
Many people like to start out
with this incremental
definition because it's
very physical.
But it makes all the mathematics
much, much harder.
And so, it's just a question
of what you prefer.
I like to start out with
something clean, then derive
things, and then say, does
it make any sense for the
physical situation?
And that's what we usually do.
We don't usually start out with
a physical situation and
analyze the hell out of it and
say, aha, this is a Poisson
process because it satisfies
all these properties.
It never satisfies all
those properties.
I mean, you say it's a Poisson
process because a Poisson
process is simple and you can
get some insight from it, not
because it really is
a Poisson process.
Let's talk about taking two
independent Poisson processes.
Just to be a little more
precise, two counting
processes, N1 of t and N2 of t
are independent if for all t1
up to t sub n the random
variables N1 of t1 to N1 of tn
are independent of N1 of
t1 up to N2 of tn.
Why don't I just say that for
all t they're independent?
Because I don't even know
what that means.
I mean, we've never defined
independence for an infinite
number of things.
So all we can do is say, for all
finite sets, we have this
independence.
Now, give you a short
pop quiz.
Suppose that instead of doing it
this way, I say, for all t1
to tn the random variables
N1 of t1 to N1 of tn are
independent of for all tao1,
tao2, tao3, tao4, N2 of tao1
up to N2 of tao sub n?
That sounds much more
general, doesn't it?
Because it's saying that I can
count one process at one set
of times and the other process
at another set of times.
Now, why isn't it any more
general to do it that way?
Well, it's an unfair pop quiz
because if you can answer that
question in the short one
sentence answer that you'd be
willing to give in a class like
this, I would just give
you A plus and tell
you go away.
And you already know all the
things you should know.
The argument is the following,
if you order these different
times, first tao1 of tao1 is
less than t1 then t1, if
that's the next one, and you
order them all along.
And then you apply this
definition to
that ordered set.
t1, tao1, t2, t3, t4, tao2, t5,
tao3, and so forth, and
you apply this definition, and
then you get the other
definition.
So one is not more general
than the other.
The theorem then, is that if
N1 of t and N2 of t are
independent Poisson processes,
one of them has
a rate lambda 1.
One of them has a
rate lambda 2.
And if N of t is equal to N1 of
t plus N2 of t, that just
means for every t this random
variable N of t is the sum of
the random variable N1
of t plus the random
variable N2 of 2.
This is true for all.
This is, definition, for all t
greater than 0, then the sum N
of t is a Poisson process of
rate lambda equals lambda 1
plus lambda 2.
Looks almost obvious,
doesn't it?
I said that today there
was lots of fun stuff.
There's also a little bit of
ugly stuff and this is one of
those half obvious things
that's ugly.
And I'm not going to waste
a lot of time on it.
You can read all about the
details in the notes.
But I will spend a little
bit of time on it
because it's important.
The idea is that if you look at
any small increment, t to t
plus delta, the number of
arrivals in the interval t to
t plus delta is equal to the
number of arrivals in the
interval t to t plus delta from
the first process plus
that in the second process.
So the probability that there's
one arrival in this
combined process is the
probability that there's one
arrival in the first process and
no arrivals in the second
process, or that there's no
arrivals in the first process
and one arrival in the
second process.
That's just a very simple
case of convolution.
Those are the only ways
you can get one in
the combined process.
This term here is delta
times lambda 1--
too early in the morning.
I'm confusing my deltas
and lambdas.
There are too many
of each of them.
--plus o of delta.
And this term here, probability
that there's zero
for the second process
is 1 minus delta
lambda 2 plus o of delta.
And then this term is just
the opposite term
corresponding to this.
Now I multiply these
terms out.
And what do I get?
Well, this 1 here combines
with a delta lambda 1.
Then there's a delta lambda 2
times delta lambda 1, which is
delta squared.
It's a delta squared term,
so that's really
an o of delta term.
It's negligible as delta
goes to zero.
So we forget about that.
There's an o of delta times 1,
that's still an o of delta.
There's an o of delta times
a delta lambda.
And that's sort of an o of delta
squared if you wish.
But it's still an o of delta.
It goes to zero as
delta gets large.
And goes to zero faster
than delta.
What we're trying to do is to
find the terms that are
significant in terms of delta.
Namely, when delta gets very
small, I want to find things
that are at least proportional
to delta and not of lower
order than delta.
So when I get done with all of
that, this is delta times
lambda 1 plus lambda
2 plus o of delta.
That's the incremental property
that we want a
Poisson process to have.
So it has that incremental
property.
And those are the same sort of
argument if you want to for
the number of arrivals in
t, that t plus delta.
Maybe a picture of
this would help.
Pictures always help
in the morning.
Here we have two processes.
We're looking at some interval
of time, t to t plus delta.
t to plus delta.
And we might have
an arrival here.
We might have an arrival
here, an arrival
here, an arrival here.
Well, the probability of an
arrival here and an arrival
here is something of order
delta squared.
So that's something we ignore.
So it says, we might have
an arrival here
and no arrival here.
This is a lambda 1.
This is lambda 2 here.
We might have an arrival here
and none here, or we might
have an arrival here
and none there.
Two arrivals is just too
unlikely to worry about, so we
forget about it at least
for the time being.
Now, after going through this
incremental argument, if you
go back and say, let's forget
about all these o of deltas
because they're very confusing,
let's just do the
convolution knowing
what N of t is in
both of these intervals.
If you do that, it's much easier
to find out that the
number of arrivals in this
sum of intervals.
Number arrivals here, plus the
number of arrivals here, this
is Poisson.
This is Poisson.
You add two Poisson,
you get Poisson.
The rate of the sum of the
two Poisson is Poisson.
So it's Poisson with lambda
1 plus lambda 2.
Now how many of you saw that
and says, why is this idiot
going through this incremental
argument?
Anyone?
I won't be embarrassed.
I knew it anyway.
And I did it for a reason.
But I must confess, when I wrote
the first edition of
this book I didn't
recognize that.
So I went through this terribly
tedious argument.
Anyway, the more important issue
is if you have the sum
of many, many small independent
arrival
processes--
OK, in other words, you
have the internet.
And a node in the internet is
getting jobs, or messages,
from all sorts of people, and
all sorts of processes, and
all sorts of nonsense going to
all sorts of people, all sorts
of processes, and all sorts
of nonsense and those are
independent of each
other, not really
independent of each other.
But relative to the data rate
that's travelling over this
internet, each of
those processes
are very, very small.
And what happens is the sum of
many, many small independent
arrival processes tend to be
Poisson even if the small
processes are not.
In a sense, the independence
between the processes
overcomes the dependence between
successive arrivals in
each process.
Now, I look at that and I say,
well, it's sort of a
plausibility argument.
You look at the argument in
the text, and you say, ah,
it's sort of a plausibility
argument.
I mean, proving this statement,
you need to put a
lot of conditions on it.
And you need to really go
through an awful lot of work.
It's like proving the central
limit theorem, but it's
probably harder than that.
So, if you read the text,
and say you don't really
understand the argument there,
I don't understand it either
because I don't think
it's exactly right.
And I was just trying to say
something to give some idea of
why this is plausible.
It should probably be changed.
Next we want to talk about
splitting a Poisson process.
So we start out with a
Poisson process here
and a t of rate lambda.
And what happens?
These arrivals come
to some point.
And some character is
standing there.
It's like when you're having
your passport checked when you
come back to Boston
after being away.
In some places you press a
button, and if the button come
up one way, you're sent off to
one line to be interrogated
and all sorts of junk.
And it's supposed
to be random.
I have no idea whether it's
random or not, but it's
supposed to be random.
And otherwise, you go
through and you get
through very quickly.
So it's the same sort
of thing here.
You have a bunch of arrivals.
And each arrival is effectively
randomly shoveled
this way or shoveled this way.
With probability p, it's
shoveled this way.
With probability 1 minus p,
it's shoveled this way.
So you can characterize this
switch as a Bernoulli process.
It's a Bernoulli process
because it's random and
independent from, not
time to time now,
but arrival to arrival.
When we first looked at a
Poisson process, we said it's
a sequence of random
variables.
Sometimes we look at
in terms of time.
Time doesn't really make
any difference there.
It's just a sequence of
IID random variables.
So you have a sequence of IID
random variables doing this
switching here.
You have a Poisson process
coming in.
And when you look at the
combination of the Poisson
process and the Bernoulli
process, you get some kind of
process of things
coming out here.
And another kind of process
of things coming out here.
And the theorem says, that when
you combine this Poisson
process with this independent
Bernoulli process, what you
get is a Poisson process here
and an independent Poisson
process here.
And, of course, you need to know
what the probability is
of being switched this way and
being switched that way.
Each new process clearly has a
stationary and independent
increment property.
Why is that?
Well, you look at some increment
of time and this
process here is independent
from one period of time to
another period of time.
The Bernoulli process is just
switching the terms within
that interval of time, which
is independent of all other
intervals of time.
So that when you look at the
combination of the Bernoulli
process and the Poisson
process, you have the
stationary and independent
increment property.
And each satisfies the small
If you look at very
small delta here,
unless each is Poisson.
There's a more careful argument
in the notes.
What I'm trying to do in the
lecture is not to give you
careful proofs of things, but to
give you some insight into
why they're true.
So that you can read
the proof.
And instead of going through
each line and saying, yes, I
agree with that, yes, I agree
with that and you finally come
to the end of the proof
and you think what?
Which I've done all the time
because I don't really know
what's going on.
And you don't learn anything
from that kind of proof.
If you're surprised when it's
done it means you ought to go
back and look at it more
carefully because there's
something there that you didn't
understand while it was
wandering past you.
The small increment property
really doesn't make it clear
that the split processes
are independent.
And for independence both
processes must sometimes have
arrivals in the same
small increment.
And this independence
is hidden in
those o of delta terms.
And if you want to resolve that
for yourself, you really
have to look at the text.
And you have to do
some work too.
The nice thing about combining
and splitting is that you
typically do them together.
Most of the places where you
use combining and splitting
you use both of them
repeatedly.
The typical thing you do is
first, you look at separate
independent Poisson processes.
And you take those separate
independent Poisson processes,
and you say, I want to look at
those as a combined process.
And after you look at them as
a combined process, you then
split them again.
And what you're doing, when you
then split them again, is
you're saying these two
independent Poisson processes
that I started with, I can
view them as one Poisson
process plus a Bernoulli
process.
And you'd be amazed at how many
problems you can solve by
doing that.
You will be amazed when you
do the homework this time.
If you don't use that property
at least 10 times, you haven't
really understood what's being
asked for in those problems.
Let's look at a simple
example.
Let's look at a last come,
first served queue.
Last come, first served queues
are rather peculiar.
They are queues where arrivals
come in, and for some reason
or other, when a new arrival
comes in that arrival goes
into the server immediately.
And the queue gets backed up.
Whatever was being served
gets backed up.
And the new arrival gets served,
which is fine for the
new arrival, unless another
arrival comes
in before it finishes.
And then it gets
backed up too.
So things get backed
up in the queue.
And those that are lucky
enough to get
through, get through.
And those that aren't, don't.
Anybody have any
idea why that--
I mean, it sounds like a very
unfair thing to do.
But, in fact, it's not unfair
because you're not singling
out any particular group
or anything.
You're just that's
the rule you use.
And it applies to everyone
equally, so it's not unfair.
But why might it make
sense sometimes?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you're doing a
first come, first served
you're going to have a
certain distribution
for your serve time.
Whereas, if you do last
come, first served--
I don't know.
I'm just trying to think that
there might some situations
where the distribution of
service times in that is
favorable overall, even though
some people, every once in a
while, are feeling screwed.
PROFESSOR: It's a good try.
But it's not quite right.
And, in fact, it's not right for
a Poisson process because
for a Poisson process the server
is just chunking things
out at rate mu, no
matter what.
So it doesn't really
help anyone.
If you have a heavy tail
distribution, if somebody who
comes in and requires an
enormous amount of service,
then you get everybody else
done first because that
customer with a huge service
requirement keeps getting
pushed back every time the queue
is empty he gets some
service again.
And then other people come in.
And people with small service
requirements get served quickly.
And what that means
is it's not quite
as crazy as it sounds.
But the reason we want to look
at it here is because it's a
nice example of this
combining and
splitting of Poisson processes.
So how does that happen?
Well, you view services
as a Poisson process.
Namely, we have an exponential
server here, where the time
for each service is
exponentially distributed.
Now, if you're awake, you point
out, well, what happens
when the server has
nothing to do?
Well, just suppose that there's
some very low priority
set of jobs that the server
is doing, which also are
exponentially distributed that
the server goes to when it has
nothing to do.
So the server is still doing
things exponentially at rate
lambda, but if there's nothing
real to do then
the output is wasted.
So that's a Poisson process.
The income is Poisson also.
So the arrival process, plus the
service process, they're
independent.
So they're Poisson.
And the rate is lambda
plus mu.
Now, interesting question,
what's the probability that an
arrival completes service before
being interrupted?
I'm lucky, I get into
the server.
I start getting served.
What's the probability that
I finish before I get
interrupted?
Well, I get into service
at a particular time t.
I look at this combined Poisson
process of arrivals
and services and if the first
arrival in this combined
process gets switched to
service, I'm done.
If gets switched to arrival,
I'm interrupted.
So the question is, what's the
probability that I get
switched to--
I want to find the probability
that I'm interrupted, so
what's the probability that a
new arrival in the combined
process gets switched to
arrivals because that's the
case where I get interrupted.
And it's just lambda.
The probability that I get
interrupted is lambda divided
by lambda plus mu.
And the probability that I
complete my service is mu over
lambda plus mu.
When mu is very large, when the
server is going very, very
fast, I have a good chance
of finishing before being
interrupted.
When it's the other
way, I have a much
smaller chance of finishing.
More interesting, and more
difficult case, given that
you're interrupted, what is the
probability that you have
no further interruptions?
In other words, I'm being
served, I get interrupted, so
now I'm sitting at the
front of the queue.
Everybody else that came in
before me is in back of me.
I'm sitting there at the
front of the queue.
This interrupting customer
is being served.
What's the probability that I'm
going to finish my service
before any further interruption
occurs?
Have to be careful about
how to state this.
The probability that there is
no further interruption is
that two services occur before
the next arrival.
And the probability of that is
mu over lambda plus mu the
quantity squared.
Now, whether you agree with
that number or not is
immaterial.
The thing I want you to
understand is that this is a
method which you can use
in quite complicated
circumstances.
And it's something that applies
in so many places that
it's amazing.
OK, let's talk a little
bit about
non-homogeneous Poisson processes.
Maybe the most important
application of this is optical
transmission.
There's an optical stream of
photons that's modulated by
variable power.
Photon stream is reasonably
modeled as a Poisson process,
not perfectly modeled
that way.
But again, what we're doing here
is saying, let's look at
this model.
And then, see whether the
consequences of the model
apply to the physical
situation.
The modulation converts the
steady photon rate into a
variable rate.
So the arrivals are being
served, namely, they're being
transmitted at some
rate, lambda of
t, where t is varying.
I mean, the photons have
nothing to do the
information at all.
They're just random photons.
And the information is
represented by lambda t.
The question is can
you actually send
anything this way?
We model the number of photons
in any interval t and t plus
delta as a Poisson random
variable whose rate parameter
over t and t plus delta, or
very small delta, is the
average photon rate over t and
t plus delta times delta.
So we go through this small
increment model again.
But in the small increment
model, we have a lambda t
instead of a lambda and
everything else is the same.
And when you carry this
out, what you find--
and I'm not going to show
this or anything.
I'm just going to tell it to you
because it's in the notes
if you want to read
more about it.
The probability that you have a
given number of arrivals in
some given interval is a Poisson
random variable again.
Namely, whether the process
is homogeneous or not
homogeneous, if the original
photons are Poisson then what
you wind up with is
this parameter
of the Poisson process.
m hat to the N e the minus m
hat divided by n factorial.
And this parameter
here is what?
It's the overall arrival
rate in that interval.
So it's exactly what you'd
expect it to be.
So what this is saying is
combining and splitting
non-homogeneous processes
still works like in the
homogeneous case.
The independent exponential
in arrivals don't work.
OK, let me say that
another way.
When you're looking at
non-homogeneous Poisson
processes, looking at them in
terms of a Poisson counting
process is really a
neat thing to do.
Because all of the Poisson
counting process formulas
still work.
And all you have to do when
you want to look at the
distribution of the number
arrivals in an interval is
look at the average arrival
rate over that interval.
And that tells you everything.
When you look at the
interarrival times and things
like that they aren't
exponential anymore.
And none of that works.
So you get half the pie, but
not the whole thing.
Now, the other thing, which is
really fun, and which will
take us a bit of time, is to
study, now it's not a small
increment but a bigger
increment, of a Poisson
process when you condition
on N of t.
In other words, if somebody
tells you how many arrivals
have occurred by time t, how do
you analyze where those are
arrivals occur, where the
arrival epochs are,
and things like that?
Well, since we're conditioning
on N of t, let's start out
with N of t equals 23 because
that's obviously the simplest
number to start out with.
Obviously not.
We start out with N of t equals
1 because that clearly
is a simpler thing
to start with.
So here's the situation
we have.
We're assuming that there's
a one arrival
up until this time.
That one arrival has to
occur somewhere in
this interval here.
We don't know where it is.
So we say, well, let's suppose
that it's in the interval s1
to s1 plus delta and try to find
the probability that it
actually is in that interval.
So we start out with something
that looks ugly.
But we'll see it isn't as
ugly as it looks like.
We'll look at the conditional
density of s1 given that N of
t is equal to 1.
That's what this is.
This is a conditional
density here.
And we say, well, how do we find
the conditional density?
This a one dimensional
density.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to look at the
probability that there's one
arrival in this tiny interval.
And then we're going to divide
by delta and that gives us the
density, if everything
is well defined.
So the density is going to be
the limit as delta goes to
zero, which is the way you
always define densities, of
the probability that there
is no arrivals in here.
That there's one arrival here.
And that there's no
arrivals here.
So probability zero
Probability of one
arrival here.
And probability of zero
arrivals here.
We want to find that
probability.
We want to divide for the
conditioning by the
probability that there was one
arrival in the whole interval.
This delta here is because we
want to go to the limit and
get a density.
OK, when we look at this and
we calculate this, e to the
minus lambda s1 is
what this is.
Lambda delta times e to
the minus lambda delta
is what this is.
And e to the minus lambda
t minus s1 minus delta
is what this is.
Because this last interval is
t minus s1 minus delta.
Now, the remarkable thing is
when I add, I multiply e to
the minus lambda s1 times e to
the minus lambda delta times e
to the minus lambda t minus
s1 minus delta.
There's an s1 here.
An s1 one here.
There's a delta here.
And a delta here.
This whole thing is e to
the minus lambda delta.
And it cancels out with this e
to the minus lambda delta.
That's going to happen
no matter how many
arrivals I put in here.
So that's an interesting
thing to observe.
So what I wind up with is lambda
delta up here, lambda
delta t here, and
my probability
density is 1 over t.
And now we look at that and we
say, my God, how strange.
And then we look at it
and we say, oh, of
course, it's obvious.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why do you use N s1
and then the N tilde for the
other two in the first
part in the limit?
PROFESSOR: Here?
AUDIENCE: You have p and s1 and
it's e N tilde on the top.
Why do you use the N
and the N tilde?
PROFESSOR: N of t is not
shown in the figure.
N of t just says there is one
arrival up until time t, which
is what lets me draw
the figure.
AUDIENCE: I meant in
the limit as delta
approaches zero, Pn, Professor.
You used Pn and then Pn tilde
for the other two.
Does that signify anything?
PROFESSOR: OK, this term is the
probability that we have
no arrivals between
zero and s1.
This N tilde means number of
arrivals in an interval, which
starts at s1 and goes
to s1 plus delta.
So this is the probability we
have one arrival somewhere in
this interval.
And this term here is the
probability that we have no
arrivals in s1 plus
delta up until t.
And when we write all of those
things out everything cancels
out except the 1 over t.
And then we look at that
and we say, of course.
If you look at the small
increment definition of a
Poisson process, it says that
arrivals are equally likely at
any point along here.
If I condition on the fact that
there's been one arrival
in this whole interval, and
they're equally likely to
occur anywhere along here, the
only sensible thing that can
happen is that the probability
density for where that arrival
happens is uniform over
this whole interval.
Now, the important point
is that this
doesn't depend on s1.
And it doesn't depend
on lambda.
That's a little surprising
also.
I mean, we have this Poisson
process where arrivals are
dependent on lambda, but you
see, as soon as you say N of t
equals 1, you sort
of wash that out.
Because you're already
conditioning on the fact that
there was only one arrival
by this time.
So you have this nice
result here.
But a result which looks
a little suspicious.
Well, we were successful
with that.
Let's go on to N
of t equals 2.
We'll get the general
picture with this.
We want to look at the
probability density of
arrivals at s1.
This s1 and an arrival here,
given that there were only two
arrivals overall.
And again, we take the limit
as delta goes to zero.
And we take a little delta
interval here, a little delta
interval here.
So we're finding the probability
that there are two
arrivals, one between s1 and
s1 plus delta and the other
one between s2 and
s2 plus delta.
So that probability should be
proportional to delta squared.
And we're dividing by delta
squared to find the joint
probability density.
You don't believe that, go back
and look at how joint
probability densities
are the defined.
I mean, you have to define
them somehow.
So you have to look at the
probability in a small area.
And then shrink the
area to zero.
And the area of the area
is delta squared.
And you have to divide
by delta squared as
you go to the limit.
OK, so, we do the same thing
that we did before.
The probability of no arrivals
in here is e to the
minus lambda s1.
In other words, we are taking
the unconditional probability
and then we're dividing by the
conditioning probability.
So the probability that there's
nothing arriving in
here is that.
The probability there's one
arrival in here is that.
Probability that there's
nothing in
this interval is this.
Probability there's one in this
interval is lambda delta
times e to the minus
lambda delta.
And finally, this last term
here, we have to divide by
delta squared to go
to a density.
We have to divide by the
probability that there were
actually just two
arrivals here.
Well, again, the same
thing happens.
If we take all the exponentials,
lambda s1,
lambda delta, lambda 2
in here, this term
cancels out this term.
This term here cancels
out this term.
And all we're left with is e to
the minus lambda t up here,
e to the minus lambda
t down here.
And because the PMF function for
N of t is e to the minus
lambda t over n factorial, n
factorial for n equals 2 is 2.
We wind up with 2
over t squared.
Now that's a little
bit surprising.
I'm going to show you a picture
in just a little bit,
which makes it clear what
that 2 is doing there.
But let's not worry about it too
much for the time being.
The important thing
here is, again,
it's independent lambda.
And it's a independent
of s1 and s2.
Namely, given that there are two
arrivals in here doesn't
make any difference
where they are.
This is, in some sense, uniform
over s1 and s2.
And I have to be more careful
about what uniform means here.
But we'll do that in
just a little bit.
Now we can do the same thing
for N of t equals N, for
arbitrary N. And when I put
in an arbitrary number of
arrivals here I still get this
property that when I take e to
the minus lambda of this region,
e to the minus lambda
times this region, this, this,
this, this, this, this and so
forth, when I get all done, it's
e to the minus lambda t.
And it cancels out with
this term down here.
We've done that down here.
And what you come up with is
this joint density is equal to
N factorial over t to the N. So
again, it's the same story.
It's uniform.
It doesn't depend on where the
s's are, except for the fact
that s1 is less than
s2 is less than s3.
We have to sort that out.
It has this peculiar N factorial
here that doesn't
depend on lambda, as I said.
It does depend N in this way.
That's a uniform N dimensional
probability density over the
volume t to the N over N
factorial corresponding to the
constraint region zero less than
s1 less than blah, blah,
blah, less than s
sub N. Now that
region is a little peculiar.
This N factorial is
a little peculiar.
The t to the N is
pretty obvious.
Because when you have a joint
density over t things, each
bounded between zero and
t, you expect to see
a t to the N there.
So if you ask, what's
going on?
In a very simple minded way, the
question is how did this
derivation know that the volume
of s1 to sn over zero
less than s1, less than sn, less
than s2, is N factorial
over t to the N?
I have a uniform probability
density over
some strange volume.
And it's a strange volume
which satisfies this
constraint.
How do I know that this
is N factorial here?
Very confusing at first.
We saw the same question when
we derived the airline
density, remember?
There was an N factorial
there.
And that N factorial when
we derived the Poisson
distribution led to an
N factorial there.
And, in fact, the fact that
we were using the Poisson
distribution there is why that
N factorial appears here.
It was because we stuck that
in when we were doing the
derivation of the Poisson PMF.
But it still seems a
little mystifying.
So I want to try to resolve
that mystery.
And to resolve it
let's look at a
supposedly unrelated problem.
And the unrelated problem is the
following, suppose U1 up
to U sub n are n IID random
variables, independent and
identically distributed random
variables, each uniform
over zero to t.
Well, now, the probability
density for those n random
variables is very,
very simple.
Because each one of them is
uniform over one to t.
The joint density is
1 over t to the n.
OK, no problem there.
They're each independent.
So the probability densities
multiply.
Each one has a probability
density 1 over t.
No matter where it is because
it's uniform.
So you multiply them together.
And no matter where you are in
this n dimensional cube, the
probability density is
1 over t to the n.
The next thing I want
to do is define--
now these are supposedly not the
same random variables as
these arrival epochs
we had before.
These are just defined
in terms of these
uniform random variables.
You're seeing a good example
here of why in probability
theory we start out with axioms,
we derive properties.
and we don't lock ourselves in
completely to some physical
problem that we're
trying to solve.
Because if we had locked
ourselves completely into a
Poisson process, we wouldn't
even be able to look at this.
We'd say, ah, that's nothing
to do with our problem.
But it does.
So wait.
We're going to define
s1 as the minimum of
U1 up to U sub n.
In other words, these are
the order statistics of
U1 up to U sub n.
I choose U1 to be anything
between zero and t, U2 to be
anything between zero and t.
And then I choose s1 to be the
smaller of those two and s2 to
be the larger of those two.
This is zero to t.
And here is say, U1.
And here is U2.
And then I transfer and call
this s1 and this s2.
And if I have a U3 out here then
this becomes s2 and this
becomes s3.
So the order statistics are
just, you take these
arrivals and you--
well, they don't have
to be arrivals.
They're whatever they are.
They're just uniform
random variables.
And I just order them.
So now my question is, the
region of volume t to the n,
name I have a volume t to the n,
for the possible values of
U1 up to U sub n.
That volume where the density of
Un is non-zero, I can think
of it as being partitioned
into n factorial regions.
First region is U1 less
than U2, and so
forth up to U sub n.
The second one is U2 is less
than U1, less than U3
and so forth up.
And for every permutation of
U1 to U sub n, I get a
different ordering here.
I don't even care about
the ordering anymore.
All I care about is that the
number of permutations of U1
to U sub n--
or the integers one
to n, really is
what I'm talking about.
Number of permutations of
1 to n is n factorial.
And for each one of those
permutations, I can talk about
the region in which the first
permutation is less than the
second permutation less than
the third and so forth.
Those are disjoint--
they have to be the same
volume by symmetry.
Now how does that symmetry
argument work there?
I have n integers.
There's no way to tell the
difference between them,
except by giving them names.
And each of them corresponds
to a IID random variable.
And now, what I'm saying is that
the region which U1 is
less than U2 has the same area
as the region where U2
is less than U1.
And the argument is whatever you
want to do with U1 and U2
to find the area of that, I
can take your argument and
every time you've written a U1,
I'll substitute U2 for it.
And every time you've
written a U2 I'll
substitute U1 for it.
And it's the same argument.
So that if you find the area
using your permutation, I get
the same area just using
your argument again.
And I can do this for as many
terms as I want to.
OK, so this says that from
symmetry each volume is the
same and thus, each volume
is t to the N
divided by N factorial.
Now the region where s sub N is
non-zero, s sub N are these
ordering statistics.
These are the terms in which you
wanted less than U2 less
than U sub n after
I reordered them.
The volume of the region where
S1 is less than S2 less than
Sn less than or equal to t, the
region of that volume is
exactly t to the N divided
by N factorial.
Because it's one over
N factorial
of the entire region.
Now, you just have to think
about that symmetry argument
for a while.
The other thing you can do is
just integrate, which is what
we did when we were deriving
the airline distribution.
I mean, you just integrate
the thing out.
And you find out that
that N factorial
magically appears there.
I think you get a better idea
of what's going on here.
Let me go on to this slide,
which will explain a little
bit what's going on here.
Suppose I'm looking
at S1 and S2.
The area where S1 is less
than S2 is this cross
hatched area here.
All the points in here
are points where S2
is bigger than S1.
As advertised, the region where
S2 is bigger than S1 has
the same area as the region
where S2 is less than S1.
And all I'm saying is this same
property happens for N
equals 3, N equals
4, and so forth.
And the argument there really
is a symmetry argument.
OK, I don't want to worry
about what the
x's are at this point.
I'm just showing you that a
little tiny area volume there
has to be part of
this triangle.
And I get that factor
of 2 because as S2
is bigger than S1.
Let me give you an example of
using the ordering statistics,
which we just talked about.
Namely, looking at N IID random
variables, and then
choosing S1 to be the smallest,
S2 to be the next
smallest and so forth.
What we've seen is that this S1
to S sub N is identically
distributed to the problem of
the epochs of arrivals in a
Poisson process conditional on
N arrivals up until time t.
So we can use either the uniform
distribution and
ordering or we can use
Poisson results.
Either one can give us results
about either process.
Here what I'm going to do is use
order statistics to find
the distribution function of S1
conditional on N arrivals
until time N. Conditional in
the fact that I found 1,000
arrivals up until time 1,000.
I want to find the distribution
function of when
the first arrival occurs.
Now, if I know that 1,000
arrivals have occurred by time
1,000, the first arrival is
probably going to be pretty
close to a Poisson
random variable.
But I'd like to see that.
OK, so the probability that
the minimum of these U sub
i's, these uniform random
variables, is bigger than S1
is the product of the
probabilities that each one is
bigger than S1.
The only way that the minimum
can be bigger than S1 is that
each of them are
bigger than S1.
So this is the product from
I equals 1 to N of 1
minus S1 over t.
Then we take the product of
things that are all the same.
It's 1 minus S1 over t to the
N. And then I go into the
domain of these arrival
epochs.
And the probability that the
first arrival epoch, the
complimentary distribution
function of that, is then 1
minus S1 over t to the N.
You can also find the expected
value of S1 just by
integrating this.
Namely, integrate the
complimentary distribution
function to get the
expected value.
And what do you get?
You get t over N plus 1.
A little surprising, but
not as surprising
as you would think.
We're looking at an interval
from zero to t.
We have three arrivals there.
And then we're asking where
does the first one occur?
And the argument is this
interval, this interval, this
interval, and this interval
ought to have the same
distribution.
I mean, we haven't talked about
this interval yet, but
it's there.
I mean, the last of these
arrivals is not a t, it's
somewhere before t.
So I have n plus 1
intervals on the
side of these n arrivals.
And what this is saying is the
nice symmetric result at the
expected place where S1 winds
up is at t over n plus one.
These intervals are in some
sense, at least as far as
expectation is concerned,
are uniform.
And we wind up with t over N
plus 1 as the expected value
of where the first one is.
That's nice and clean.
If you look at this problem
and you think in terms of
little tiny arrivals coming in
any place, and, in fact, you
look at this U1 up to U
sub N, one arrival.
I can think of it
as one arrival
from each of N processes.
And these are all Poisson
processes.
They all add up to give a
joint Poisson process, a
combined Poisson process,
with N arrivals.
And then, I order the arrivals
to correspond to the overall
sum process.
And this is the answer I get.
So the uniform idea is related
to adding up lots of little
tiny processes.
OK, now the next thing I want
to do, and I can see I'm not
really going to get time to do
it, but I'd like to give you
the results of it.
If I look at a box, a little
cube, of area delta squared in
the S1, S2 space.
And I look at what that maps
in to, in terms of the
interarrivals x1 and x2, if you
just map these points into
this, you see that this square
here is going into a
parallelepiped.
And if know a little bit
of linear algebra--
well, you don't even need to
know any linear algebra to see
that no matter where you put
this little square anywhere
around here it's always going to
map into the same kind of a
parallelepiped.
So if I take this whole area and
I break it up into a grid,
this area is going to be broken
up into a grid where
it's things are going
down this way.
And this way, we're going to
have a lot of these little
tiny parallelepipeds.
If I have uniform probability
density there, I'll have
uniform probability
density there.
The place where you need some
linear algebra, if you're
dealing with n dimensions
instead of 2, is to see that
the volume of this delta cube
here, for this problem here,
is going to be identical
to the volume of
the delta cube here.
OK, so when you get all done
that, the area in the x1, x2
space where zero is less than x1
plus x2 is less than t is t
squared over 2 again.
And the probability density
of these two interarrival
intervals is again
2 over t squared.
It's the same as the arrivals.
I'm going to skip this slide.
I want to get the one other
thing I wanted to talk about a
little bit.
There's a paradox.
And the main interarrival time
for Poisson process is one
over lambda.
If I come at time t and I start
waiting for the next
arrival, the mean time I have
to wait is 1 over lambda.
If I come in and I start looking
back, at the last
arrival, well, this says it's 1
over lambda times 1 minus e
to the minus lambda t,
which is what it is.
We haven't derived that.
But we know it's something.
So, what's going on here?
I come in at time t, the
interval between the last
arrival and the next arrival,
the mean interval there is
bigger than the mean interval
between arrivals
in a Poisson process.
That is a real paradox.
And how do I explain that?
It means that if I'm waiting for
buses, I'm always unlucky.
And you're unlucky too and
we're all unlucky.
Because whenever you arrive, the
amount of time between the
last bus and the next bus is
bigger than it ought to be.
And how do we explain that?
Well, this sort of gives
you a really half-assed
explanation of it.
It's not very good.
When we study renewals, we'll
find a good explanation of it.
First choose a sample path
of a Poisson process.
I mean, start out with
a sample path.
And that has arrivals
going along.
And we want to get rid of zero
because funny things happen
around zero.
So we'll start at one eon
and stop at n eons.
And we'll look over
that interval.
And then we'll choose t to be
a random variable in this
interval here.
OK, so, we choose some
t after we've looked
at the sample path.
And then we say for this random
value of t, how big is
the interval between the
most recent arrival
and the next arrival.
And what you see is that since
I have these arrivals of a
Poisson process laid out here,
the large intervals take up
proportionally more area than
the little intervals.
If I have a bunch of little tiny
intervals and some big
intervals and then I choose a
random t along here, I'm much
more likely to choose a t in
here, proportionally, than I
am to choose a t in here.
This mean time between the
arrivals is the average of
this, this, this,
this, and this.
And what I'm looking at here
is I picked some arbitrary
point in time.
These arbitrary points in time
are likely to lie in very
large intervals.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you please explain
again what is exactly
is the paradox?
PROFESSOR: The paradox is that
the mean time between arrival
is one over lambda.
But if I arrive to look for a
bus and the buses are Poisson,
I arrive in an interval whose
mean length is larger than 1
over lambda.
And that seems strange to me.
Well, I think I'll stop here.
And maybe we will spend just
a little time sorting
this out next time.